3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
laissez-moi une seconde que je reprenne
mon souffle il était une fois rosace un
royaume bâti par un grand roi magicien
il avait le pouvoir d'exaucer les vœux
[Musique]
vous êtes leur magnifique roi bien-aimée
c'est vrai je suis un roi magnifique
ma meilleure amie continue
quand le bloquer
un chat viens avec moi les feuilles de
rosace
leurs vœux et j'exauce ce dont je suis
sûr qu'ils sont bénéfiques pour Rosas
certains de ces vœux ne seront jamais
exaucés la majorité il
mérite c'est moi qui décide ce que
chacun mérite
[Musique]
saura me guider je souhaite mes peurs je
les oublie sous le chemin
votre magie nous éblouit ce n'est pas
moi comment
hier soir j'ai confié un vœu à une
étoile
et les toiles a répondu
je parle moi je parle et en plus j'ai de
voix de velours c'est une menace qui
m'est adressée qui oserait vous menacer
là je sais pas quoi dire
[Musique]
oui
belle trouvaille Valentino ça c'était
pas fait exprès
[Musique]
j'ai commencé je dois terminer
moi je
fais qu'est-ce que tu caches
rien ni personne qu'est-ce qui se passe
ici et bien mademoiselle vous ne pouvez
pas voler mais vous pouvez chanter